[Music]
kenny is with us rather kenny is in
savannah georgia hi kenny how are you
hello dave thank you guys for taking my
call sure what's
up so
i have um so i recently came across your
show about last month and it really
motivated me to pay off my debt i was
young dumb and stupid
in the military and i accumulated a lot
of credit card cut and i also financed
the car which is another stupid decision
i made
um
but i kind of followed your debt
avalanche message
about three weeks ago and i paid off
5 000 towards my credit card so now i
only have 16 000. left overall debt for
myself my wife is different she's a
student right now she's about to
graduate with her degree
so i just want to know what's the best
way to tackle that should i keep
following the avalanche or just do with
that snowball
i already have an emergency uh fund in
place already the baby step one gotcha
okay well at ramsey we don't teach the
avalanche we teach the debt snowball
okay okay and that's listing your debts
smallest to largest
paying minimum payments on everything
but the little one and attack the little
one we also teach you that there are
that when you are married we are one the
preacher said and now you are one he
didn't say now you are a joint venture
so how much wife does your how much debt
does your wife have
so the the only debt that she has is the
school which is nineteen thousand okay
so nineteen thousand current
and then uh
to do a federal worker that way the
school paper
on that as she works for the school so
that's what she'll be doing and what
will she be making at the school
uh she will be a teacher and it will be
about um
1500 a month okay and what do you make
i make uh 52. good for you um a year a
year all right so you got about a 70 to
an 80 000 household income depending on
how many hours you all work
and you've got thirty four thousand
dollars in debt between the two of you
does that sound about right
yes sir
so what we're going to do here is do you
guys have any savings right now
any money myself
uh just myself i have about uh almost
four thousand in the bank okay so if
you're following the babysitter you're
married so that's hers too
yes yes sir all right and you guys have
one joint bank account
uh no we do not ours is separate but our
savings uh created savings for both of
us to have together
okay well i'll tell you this if you guys
want to feel the progress of this thing
you're gonna have to get on the same
page get one bank account get the goal
get the plan and do this thing together
okay because right now it sounds like
you're living two different lives
financially
okay
but what you're gonna do is have that
thousand dollars for your starter
emergency fund and everything else is
going to go towards the debt
and you're going to do the debt snowball
like dave mentioned list them all
smallest to largest and then once you're
out of consumer debt you're done with
that 34 000 we go back and we fully fund
that emergency fund with three to six
months of expenses that's going to
create this financial foundation for you
guys to where you don't have money
stress anymore so kenny what i'll do is
i'll put you on hold kelly will pick up
we're gonna send you a copy of the book
the total money makeover to show you
exactly how to do this combine your
finances
focus exclusively on the debt listing
your debts smallest balance to largest
balance that's the debt snowball you pay
minimum payments on everything with a
little when you attack the little one
with a vengeance as fast as you can no
eating out
no going on vacation
no frills beans and rice rice and beans
scorched earth syndrome around the house
there no lifestyle we're getting out of
debt how fast can we get out of debt
making 70 to 80 000 owing 34. probably
gonna take you about 18 months if you're
really really intense
and the more intense you are by the way
the faster you'll get out because the
deeper you'll sacrifice
hang on kelly will pick up we're going
to send you a copy of the total money
makeover